okay should we do this now okay aye aye
one of the problems you know we media
types type every week is that we we
don't want to keep talking about Donald
Trump but you know you also can't not
talk about Donald Trump but I realized
recently that after all the commentary
all the words printed and said every
week there's still one thing that nobody
calls Donald Trump on and look yes
sometimes I do go too far but tonight
I'm just going to say it
Donald Trump is fat Donald Trump is fat
I mean a war with everything else he's
fat he's a fat fat
you know because he's tall and he wears
these big boxy dark suits and he Jayant
tides and strides around like mr. macho
man people see him as just robust or
powerful but he's not he's fat look
here's a quick comparison there's his
ass and there's Kim Kardashian's head
[Applause]
reality stars anyway I've written a book
it's called the art of the meal a
thousand and one Trump fat jokes would
you like to hear some okay Trump so fat
most of the voices it most of the voices
in his head or chewing he's fat nobody
says it but he's fat he gets winded
riding the escalator the same guys he he
sent to get Obama's birth certificate
are now looking for his dick he he once
bragged that he moved like a on
Mrs Butterworth Oh
the book I have bestseller the banks
want to break him up his Secret Service
code name is Chris Christie